when the average everyday e-gamer tunes
into twitch it's usually to watch
someone
well
carrie whether they're a total chad
making everyone else look like trash or
simply the best there's no denying that
streaming's biggest superstars tend to
be those who fill out the flashiest
roles not just because they deserve to
but because they want to yes because i'm
simple drop me operator please
thank you
and in the vast majority of esports it's
those damage dealing savants who end up
headlining their respective streaming
categories because for better or for
worse there's this assumption that if
you're super duper cracked
you must be a carry
oh
oh my god that was dirty but suffice it
to say that isn't always the most
efficient way to exploit someone's
awesomeness in fact there are countless
cyber athletes across esports who
despite branding themselves as selfless
enablers have cemented themselves as
some of the biggest most badass
enchiladas their esport has to offer the
doom is still there down onto the medusa
the disarm as well from it to the man's
harbour
oh god
oh fy
fyff flipping one he absolutely smashes
them and in the let's say
quiet stomping grounds that his twitches
overwatch tap there is one streamer
among a handful of mainstays who's
managed to grow a huge following of
loyal adoring admirers not by hitting
sick widow flicks or earth-shattering
rhinos but by brandishing his very own
brand of awesome edifying
support
imagine if that hits that
if i be tracer go guide side
and i go to sleep like right now
probably
[Laughter]
it is confirmed i am
ml7 lupuscus the health bestowing aimbot
who's spent years not only churning out
sultry clip-worthy sleep darts but
spitting science about supporting to his
ever-growing audience if they have now
wait l7 wait for a genji to play wait
for genji to dash when genji dash you do
the bash then you whiplash
what makes ml7 such an endearing
authority of course isn't just his
god-tier game sense or masterful
mechanics but the fact that he always
manages to stay positive and upbeat in
overwatch it's a game that is
infuriating chaotic and let's be honest
chronically imbalanced
three two one now
kick w that's so unfortunate
so how did ml7 go from an aspiring
lawyer to twitch's most absurdly
talented anna abuser how is it that a
snuggly deaf kitty cat became the real
star of his stream and if he's been able
to find this much success in spite of
the waning popularity of the original
overwatch
how big could he get once the sequel
finally arrives
all right so before i dive into mihai's
journey i must ask that you like
subscribe and turn on notifications
did you like my my overwatch pun
you didn't
wow just
not pulling any punches today are we
it's not enough that i get made fun of
her playing overwatch now i have to sit
here while you just
okay so if you are like me and you are
an og supporter of overwatch's
well og supporter then it's probably for
one of the following reasons one olaf
the beautiful hard of hearing cat with
heterochromia if there would be like a
book of cat emotions olaf would be at
every page of it i guess two the fact
that he is in humanly good at geogasser
yo where are we bro
well
gotcha
everybody's gonna say gosh i'm going to
say bulgaria because this is way too
familiar
and way too similar to comedia
and of course three he's absolutely out
of this world on a play chad i'm just
gonna go wanna to sleep down the genji
because i want the clip that's the only
reason i'm going
what did i tell you
here's the thing though our boy wasn't
always twitch's filthiest
anti-administerer in fact contrary to
what you might think he didn't cut his
teeth in arena shooters at all now like
a lot of esports's crispiest aimers
ml7 was a died in the wool 1.6
what set mihai apart from all the other
european aim gods that that beautiful
difficult esport engendered was his
sensitivity let's just say that it was
pretty high
well i think that when you enter cs your
default
sensitivity set to 20 if i remember
correctly and all the like a mouse back
in the day you only had 800 dpi on them
you know not proper gaming
not a proper gaming mouse like every
every must have the standard they have
dpi so i went like
nah 20 is too much so i'm just gonna log
to 19 and i played 4.5 000 hours i think
of cs play that lens and so on in
romania with 19 sedativity and 800 dpi
and everybody was like how can you do
that what is happening as for why mihai
opted to stick with such a spin bought
tear sensitivity
he just
didn't give a [ __ ] what other people
thought
i didn't watch any guides i didn't want
to learn from anyone i guess i just went
like you know what i'm just gonna do
what phil's got for me i started with 19
sensitivity then i swapped to league of
legends i had i played that for four
years as well got to challenger
my sensitivity lord a little bit then i
swapped to overwatch and i guess now i'm
more tempered with 807 but still for
whatever reason people think that it's
kind of fast
i don't know it's it's odd and yet in
spite of his insane inherent mechanical
talent circumstances made ml7 unable to
try his luck at the professional level
in either cs or league as for how he
ended up setting his sights on overwatch
and eventually anna it's sort of a funny
story
on
hug bug day my girlfriend
bought me overwatch she told me that yo
for my book they just try out overwatch
because you've been kind of depressed
playing league of legends
and
i i picked it up then she wanted to play
it as well fast forward a couple of
months we make a team together and i
guess we didn't have a support for our
team nobody wanted to play support
anymore
so i stopped to support then i stuck
with it that's it so you could say that
i guess
i got forced into playing support but
i've always had more of a
supportive playstyle in any game that i
played unfortunately in europe it was
even harder to go pro in overwatch than
it was in league or cs and it looked as
if his digital hopes and dreams would
never come true so mihai became somewhat
deterred and decided to turn his
analytical mindset towards the real
world instead i wanted to give up on
overwatch
and i wanted to like go full and study
to become a lawyer full-time
both me and her work in law school were
in the same class so everything we did
was together
and then she went like you know what one
last guy it's been your dream to try to
do something gaming related ever since
you're young so just do it one last guy
let's try streaming if you like it fine
if you don't like it fine again after a
couple of streams i'm like god damn what
have i been doing with my life this is
amazing with his partner helping to
manage and produce his stream from
behind the scenes ml7 took to streaming
like a fish to water offering fun
insightful and educational content for
those looking to take up what arguably
was and still is overwatch's most skill
intensive support to look like see how
how many seconds you're exposed to
getting a random headshot you could
still heal like your main goal should be
to try and dish out as much damage as
possible but you can't do damage because
they have a grind shield so you need to
do damage when the tanks go in so you
need to be like just be a little hillbot
kill your tanks up when they move in you
move in and you try to do damage but
just being covered and try to get your
nano as fast as possible thanks in part
to his high sensitivity ml7 was able to
put on some amazing performances with
overwatch's grandmotherly healer showing
that if you were good enough there was
almost nothing her kit couldn't counter
what the hell
who
sleeping top left on the stacks of
victims
before long ml7 had cemented himself as
twitch's go-to honor educator the one
high level support specialist who pretty
much always locked her in no matter what
and some of you may not know this but at
the time
that wasn't actually considered to be a
good thing and i remember that i had
like some streamers that told me a
couple months ago that everybody was
avoiding me
because i played anna and i refused to
play mercy and i was playing in ana like
such a bad metaphor hug and somehow i
still managed to make her work
[Music]
oh
yes sir
in fact it was in part because anna was
so out of the meta when ml7 was on his
come up that he was able to become so
outrageously adept with her you have to
make the impossible possible
you have to land the impossible sleep
ducts you have to land the impossible
shots because otherwise the hair is
going to be useless over time ml7 stream
became such a celebrated mainstay that
he was able to stop juggling school with
sleep darts and start pursuing his
passion for content creation full time
the only we only had like i only took
some breaks during exam sessions but
overall i remember that i had some
pigeons in which i would probably sleep
two or three hours a night wake up law
school
come back take one hour nap stream
study sleep repeat and so on and it had
it had been going like that for a couple
of months so i tried to do my best even
though it took a toll of my uh of how
tired i was
but now looking at perspective it was
completely worked at 100
and by embracing his calling he not only
became one of the biggest support
streamers in overwatch but eventually
one of the biggest overwatch streamers
period at some point the support stick
became kind of secondary ml7 was just
the go-to educator for new and
experienced players alike you know i've
always had like a
sense of like teaching people whatever i
did
whatever i did i was like really good at
explaining really good at putting myself
in an experienced play shoes or like
an amateur somebody that never played on
their computer and stuff and i know how
fun it is to win in games
come on give me give me give me give me
give me give me give me me
[Music]
look it's no secret that over the years
overwatch has sort of
waned in popularity it struggled with
deep-seated imbalance faced hurdles as
an esport and received staggeringly
little support from blizzard but through
it all with viewership down and tons of
creators and competitors jumping ship
ml7 hasn't just gotten by
he's grown carving out a successful life
for him and his partner i've been doing
this with my partner from the beginning
and
she's doing this with me she's my social
media manager she edited edits she's one
of my editors guy now she just handles
everything overall i'm just on screen we
talk together she also coaches me if you
can't believe this it's amazing to have
like somebody
somebody like that in your life that you
love and that you can also like work it
on work on work with on the stuff that
you like as well oh and let's not forget
olaf
[Music]
it is worth highlighting the fact that
ml7 has built a thriving community
around
what a lot of people would consider
however jokingly
a dead game and he's done it from the
far away shores of romania what's more
he's shining a much needed light on how
hard it is to clap cheeks as a tank or
dps without a smoke show of a support
babysitting them every step of the way
ciao look at this
wait wait forget look
wait for the dog to open look up sucks
a
okay stop looking now
what you need to do is you need to take
the support out to restaurants you need
to go in vacations you need to ask how
the support today was you need to ask
how they feel about their plans the
future take care of them make them feel
safe make them feel appreciated
and if you do that your sport will be
the best support in the entire world but
if you're being a selfish piece of [ __ ]
that can see what an amazing support you
have near you you will not get the
proper results i'm sorry that's how it
is that's how it is
take care of your supports and the
supports will take care of you simple as
that but more importantly he has managed
to do the one thing that every creator
must do if they want to not only survive
making content about the game they love
but thrive
stay excited about it i still want to
innovate i'm still finding ways of
playing the game every day i'm still
learning new ways i'm still learning a
ton i've expanded my hero pool a lot
like when i started playing support i
just went like instead of being mediocre
at everything i'm just going to be
really good at something so i started
playing ghana and then i swapped to
baptist or when baptist was released i
was like um yeah
now that felt amazing just gave me like
all cs vibes
no one would deny that overwatch has
become rather stale but by waking up
every day and coming up with new
inventive ways to keep it fresh from
road to gm on every hero to getting pot
g on every hero to meming in community
modes mihai keeps drawing blood from the
stone as long as you can find
happiness in what you're doing and you
strongly believe that what you're doing
is
makes you happy and it's valuable to
people around you
then you will
you'll do well i guess but that doesn't
mean that you should stop innovating i
feel like people just get comfortable
like i don't like the term content
creator and again i know that it's
cringe but as a content creator you have
to create content
i think this is doable get steep back
and get a final blow with flashbang
who's the most toxic tank in the game
one that annoys people if you t back
with them
hog who might be toxic from them
reinhardt no junket might be toxic
just deep back him
he back him too
d back m2 just see [ __ ] everybody
wait he left the game wait too much wait
bro
t-bag m2
and with overwatch 2 already in beta and
excitement starting to build around the
sea of radical experimental changes it's
slated to implement the hope is that
mihai's stream can get even bigger but
no matter when the sequel ships or how
revolutionary it ends up being
one thing is for certain ml7 and his
partner will never stop ideating
innovating and delivering the best
product possible to their feral olaf
obsessed community which at the end of
the day
is
sort of what being a content creator is
all about
i don't want to sound cognier whatever
but i feel very lucky to be able to do
this as a career you know what email i'm
really proud of you because the first
interaction with me was meet rash
talking you and ryan because you kept
playing anna in mercy meta and look at
you now
here's the thing though our boy wasn't
always twitch's filthiest
anti-administer
[Music]
here's the thing though our boy wasn't
always twitch's filthiest
anti-administer in fact contrary to what
you might think he didn't cut his teeth
in arena shooters at all
now like a lot of esports's crispiest
aimers ml7 was a oh my god
all right this line just has it out for
me bro it's just this line is just it
just has my number bro this this line is
my 13th reason as ryan would say
okay